hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to my friends - let's see
how much I'm not her - I'm his first
play she's an investigative journalist
given leads on the creepiest place in
town the Arcadians the derelict hotel
now home honey cooker and junkie who
dare to stay there but with a crooked
past I haven't heard from her in days
something didn't feel right I had to
find her at any cost
oh we are that's why we're playing okay
oh sorry I didn't know that those gonna
be an intro by the time I got in here so
is your friend one of those hooker and
junkies person that you were talking
about where's your friend just an
investigative journalist eka lost in
here and now you as a responsible friend
wants to find her so that you can be
rewarded with super friendship
yeah me an okay anyway so we're in a
house hotel thingy but where are all
these junkies you're talking about
what's this a real glow hello
click since I got here I keep getting
the feeling I'm being watched I was
turned that someone was murdered in room
41 I'll start there and see what I can
find
I can turn the flashlight on and off
with the right click and open the doors
with F well that seemed strange in this
real world that we live in but however I
will not abide by that curtain tink why
would the open doors button be F and the
flashlight be right click this game
don't make no sense
ha what is this is made on the you oh
don't tell me oh [ __ ] why was this a
Slenderman game I was under no
impression that there who's gonna be
Slendy man in here hello okay anyway
42 was that the one where the murder
happened in or was it 41
hang on I'm just gonna wait no that's
just leading to the other way
all right let's see what we got Oh
champagne bottles on the floor your that
or puke by the same thing 41 yeah murder
all right hello hello hello hello there
we go
some strange things have been happening
I'm starting to feel like I'm not alone
I heard a voice calling me from room 39
the same room the murder burger is
staying in against my instincts I'll see
what I can find in there well thank you
for keeping an orderly okay thanks for
keeping an orderly journals go say but
whoo I gave you everything you were my
everything now you are nothing
always nothing the Slenderman symbol but
why Dabu earning he'll fit more never
forgive never forget you broke me all
right so some lover's quarrel of some
sort I'm supposing this is a maze Oh am
I supposed to find room 39 I rather find
room 69 hey so funny I'm so funny okay
so I'm obviously going the wrong way
Chuck stricter chugga choo choo
okay so 30 I must be down this hallway
somewhere what triggers took it took
what took a chugga-chugga expect more
high-quality humor once I get in here Oh
to glowy things oh well
gimme I found a diary of sorts plying to
the murderer he was clearly a nut job
but I'm stuck to follow it up I'm sure
there must be some sort of clue around
here
what rum
ah I see it X X I X uh yeah okay all
right die Oh God I saw her looking at me
again today those perfect green eyes
Pyrrha could Pierce Steele and I could
tell she loves me too
she's been staying at Hotel for three
days now but we have loved lifetime
worth the morrow ah pluck up courage to
introduce self that's are not right I
saw her eating and laughing with man at
breakfast
it hurts another man make her smile like
that I haven't met her yet so I will
forgive her this okay so it dribbles out
a little bit craziness goes on see red
man came in sleep he tells love and
justice can't take anymore Isabel what
have you done I loved you I'm so angry I
am so angry I am so as sad if I can't
have you nobody will okay he's a little
kid throwing a tantrum Oh Leslie here
the 10 times 10 minus 9 84 yep nothing I
can do that too ok let's carry on and
not keep ourselves out and see what's
lying in the darkness we're looking for
room 29 I was just feigning dumbness
there those are Roman numerals in case
you guys didn't know someone behind it
okay just checking how about now to the
left right I don't know whoa what uh
hello
whose finger-painting why why would you
do that that's awfully rude okay who's
room 31 I hear a heartbeat coming from
behind that door maybe it's around on
the other side also fine room 29 hello
there's somebody there ah
okay room 30 I'm getting close chuka
chuka oh the music is getting louder
yeah alright 29 come closer I think I
should this seems like a trap oh boo boo
doo buh doo buh doo buh duh buh duh duh
nothing really knows it
oh I thought something was gonna happen
I hear a heart could Bibble ah but why
is that off why is that off-center what
the hell is that does it diagur start it
guy you got me wha full game coming soon
Wow whatever okay so I don't know why
that's kind of off kilter there but it
is stowe oh no I was cool I guess it had
some weird things why was Slenderman in
there I made no sense
all right a game didn't make any sense
all I don't know but the links in the
description so if you want to play it
you can try for yourself maybe there was
something that I missed I have no idea
about so thank you all so much for
watching clicking imitates before videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
I
but
hi